vous étiez des épouses nombreux et poule
de jacques martin et bien j'ai vous
attirera au alors bien fait j'ai refusé
d'épouser
je vienne le voir
m'excuser je ne regrette pas j'ai refusé
de l'épouser à ses vrais compagnons et
compagnes j'ai eu deux enfants j'ai fait
l'amour comme hamza les géniales
d'accord
y'a pas d'âge alors eh bien vous dans
une seconde mois comme elle était prévu
qu'il avait fait sa demande et tu lui as
dit non oui j'ai toujours dit non vous
êtes la star de deux épouses about était
mariée comme passager ont douté de rien
j'ai pas de souci pas de bol alors je
lui avais alors on est là pour parler
nuit oui donc je prends la parole pour
lui voit john f j'ai connu chaque bien
avant le petit rapporteur il était même
qu'ailleurs nous étaient sans travail
sans rien me suivez moi j'ai travaillé
beaucoup je faisais quoi elle christian
tu comédienne jeu s'est bien passée mais
les portes ont
commencé à tourner les deux seules
cibles que jacques brel a réalisé avec
mme amara qui s'appelait france et
l'autre chambre est d'accord voilà donc
vous travaillez je sais que ce que je
voulais c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée de
mettre un petit enregistreur sur la
table dès dimanche elle a fait demi-tour
quoi ça je vais vous dire pourquoi je
sais ce que j'ai rencontré jacky ne
travaillaient pas ils étaient très très
drôle à table toujours mais alors il
faisait un des sketches me suivront
chaume la bénichon nul n'en ai que
faisait-il pour gagner un peu de sous il
y avait un cabaret à l'époque qui
s'appelait la tête de lard dirigé par
jacques provence et à se verdir 9h30 on
se voit que tu es fan de provence
jacques jacquot disent-ils à jacques
faire non non et non on est au fond de
sa rolls et hambourg et est ce que tu
peux venir la rue là c'est bien c'est un
nom ouais je sais jeune je lui servait
de chauffeur attaque on arrivait à la
tête de l'art il fêtait ses sketches que
je t'aimais pas au retrait maison huit
jours plus tard stephenson jacquot et à
la grande labrune est là lui elle a le
cafard turballe entrelacés et remplaçait
et là mon but est comme ça avec des
petits sketchs d'accord et à jour un
jeunot effectivement je trouvais drôle
dans la vie ceux qui l'ont connu je
voulais qu'il soit aussi drôle dans la
vie que que la personne va sur scène que
dans la vie donc vous avez vous-même
suite enregistreurs grâce à une école
arc à hull et lalla tes chances de le
faire et trois dimanches de suite il
avait son one man chez les castels à la
campagne on mettait le micro ils ne
savaient pas en trois semaines il avait
son spectacle à ses doigts tout et
pourtant alors ça m'a quand même parce
que attention je peux pas vous couper
mais en face de vous quelqu'un que
j'adore un très grand monsieur qui
rapportera oui un grand pôle péter
rapportant ces pierres bien mon
[Applaudissements]
découvert par jacques martin exactement
oui on s'était rencontrés dans 68
exactement moi je faisais une mission
pierre bonjour monsieur le maire sur
europe 1 qui donnait la parole aux
cellules genre des petits villages de
france et martin étaient venus faire la
tournée d'europe 1 sur le tour de france
participé au spectacle soir mais le dock
le dock est intéressant ça c'est qui
montre quand même que voilà c'est
exactement on en a parlé ici de claude
françois sur scène un grand monsieur
daniel rideau c'est à dire un petit
monsieur quelqu'un qui était vraiment et
avec les femmes et avec ses
collaborateurs odieux
j'écoute même bien défendu même pierre
desproges départ coûte parce qu'il
paraît qu'ils disaient qu'à des proches
situées plus loin que moi tu t'en vas
pas non mais non
qui était sympathique de la vie mais
notre
agréable ça n'empêche pas c'est un homme
il a toujours espérer qu'un jour sa
maman lui dirai je t'aime et oui toi et
medan et ça n'excuse pas tout ça où les
gens étaient tous les gens qui avaient
pas été mais correctement devait être
odieux mais licha nombreux noms mérite
peut être mal aux yeux j'ai été
malheureux son papa est mort foetale
conique sa maman s'est remarié ils ont
eu un enfant qui nous regardent jour
mans et bien ils ont mis jacques hampé
fonctions chez les curés les mots si
j'étais en pension daniel je suis comme
lui un bond des jsa cassidy pioli en
tout cas c'est toujours
non maintenant il est mort ouais nan lui
non
celui qui veut re oui il a été haut lieu
ouais je suis parti pierre a assisté à
des scènes effrayantes ouais quand je
recrute pâtissent pas si tu devais il a
cassé l'appartement la cabine tout mais
vous l'avez quitté quand même oui mais
oui d'accord mais le visent et reviens
je t'aime et que tu es moins cher
monsieur je crois que dans cette partie
de la sphère midi sur une route sud
liban comme
celui-là je suis chroniqueur
pour l'or avec monsieur n'est
pas prêt il m'a interrompu vous êtes en
train de juger demandez-le à tout casser
il avait quitté vous l'avez qui tu
parles aimanté plusieurs fois mais je
les quitte elle a bien fait parce qu'il
a été vraiment très grossier mais très
grossier je suis parti est cette fois ci
au lieu d'aller pleurer chez les collaro
toute la bande du tout nos amis j'ai dit
je ne reviens plus donc j'ai quitté un
homme que j'ai mais ouais c'est terrible
mois 2e g j ce documentaire sur paris
première pardon je n'ai pas eu alors
encore une fois je le respecte et
c'était un artiste incroyable et quand
j'ai vu le dock je n'ai pas eu ce
sentiment un peu de haut là là mais
c'était un artiste mal aimé j'ai eu le
sentiment de voir quelqu'un sinon deviez
à 200 il est aimé par dont elle était
dur avec lui même voulait tout le temps
était très exigeant et insatisfaits
perpétuel il avait tous les talents il
était pour moi le l'homme le plus
brillant qu'on ait connu à la télévision
mais il y avait toujours dans quelques
domaines que ce soit quelqu'un qui était
plus brillant que lui mais ça ils le
supportent pas les jaloux éternellement
de et pierre vous avez vous n'avez pas
vécu vous c'est vrai que ça découvre de
talent y avez vous vu des proches il
collaro après
croyez-vous ces fameuses colère pendant
les rédactions ont parfois il vous
parlais mal alors que vous avez tous un
certain âge et après 40 ans à peu près
non c'est pas comme ça moi je sais rien
on a pendant un instant
qu'elle me plaindre j'ai eu deux jours
de très bons rapports avec lui mais on
n'était pas arrivé au moins je suis pas
comme moi j'étais pas là pour faire rire
non le petit rapporteur ceux qui
souffraient c'est ce exactement il
existe ils soient drôles des balles sur
l'arrêt des primes à la manière dont
martin l'attendait travailler et donc
les ego et les styles d'humour et ça
peut parfois s'affronter désapprouvait
créer des clashs et c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec des proches
c'est lui qui me créer un personnage oui
tu n'oublieras pas que ce sera comme ça
il avait c'était un créateur il a fait
de stéphane collaro totaux de mayonnaise
bon c'est vrai que stéphanie - les mieux
moi oui la paix qui fait le plus mal s
et autres saint jacques était un
créateur créateurs et effectivement il
faisait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup la
fête qu'on comprend dans le dock aussi
sortait tout le temps et c'était une de
cm2 ces dérives aussi c'est ça vous
racontez dans le dogme ou même
d'ailleurs il y avait la boulimie et la
fête et puis une chose est certaine en
fait il n'a pas été heureux il y avait
une une chose qui ne m'est pas c'était
lorsqu'il ya les concours de télé 7
jours vous savez en fin d'année il était
dans la colonne des animateurs et ça et
voulait être shakespeare il voulait être
d'anciens 8 comme et d'acteurs la
communication
permanent alors très bien j'ai une
question où elle est un petit peu dur
mais quand on meurt seul comme il l'est
mort seul est ce que ça veut pas dire
que vous avez eu une vie où quelque part
vous vous êtes quand même vous avez été
détesté quand on meurt seul sait qu'on a
une vie qui fait en sorte qu'on a
terminé seul assis on revendait il n'a
eu d'autre moi n'ont pas pas de vous je
pars dès qu'ils arrivent personnes
venaient le voir et dans un grand hôtel
il voulait donner sur personne ils
voulaient plus
et c'est très bien que pierre vienne et
les traiter
je suis le dernier alors là c'est vrai
vous êtes le dernier la vente je les
vois bien mois à mois avant sa mort
j'allais le voir à biarritz parce que
daniel m'avait dit jacques va très mal
les médecins l'ont condamné il en a pour
un mois ou deux encore et moi j'ai
tellement de reconnaissance envers
jacques martin est tellement d'affection
pour lui je me suis dit faut que je voie
une dernière fois le pour lui dire merci
j'ai téléphoné au directeur de l'hôtel
le palais à biarritz le dire dit à
jacques que je vais venir le voir il m'a
dit ah non j'ai surtout pas lui dire si
je lui dis que tu veux venir dire non ne
le lit conjugal vous que je peuvent voir
personne donc je suis venu sans le
prévenir je descends du je suis arrivée
dans le hall le matin descendant de
l'avion et g jacques et des partis faire
des soins de chimiothérapie j'ai vu
revenir avec dans son fauteuil roulant
poussé par les infirmières infirmières
il est passé dans l'hôtel il m'a vu et
il a continué olala gobain voir ah oui
cinq minutes après il appelait il
faisait appeler par l'infirmière la
réception des antilles tapir bond que je
l'attends pour déjeuner au bord de la
piscine d'accord on n'a pas dormi on a
déjeuné ensemble et pardon il est des
valeurs l'oréal et on a évoqué le petit
rapporteur et c'était pour lui une des
périodes les plus heureuses de sa vie
comme un extrait du petit rapporteur
jean très demandée parce que j'ai eu
tellement de fiches ou pas du tout au
tout par l'alliance automatique puis
florian revenir par rapport à ce que tu
as un extrait au fait qu'il ait être
parrainé ce trait du petit rapporteur
juste d'apprécier encore vous voilà
cette mythique regarder pêche aux moules
moules mais méfiez vous seuls les moules
du petit reporter sont fraîches rêver
coût des imitations
la mouline s'est emparé de la france
entière vous avez pu le constater cette
semaine quand nous sortons dans les rues
dès que les gens voient quelqu'un de
pire à paris ou
ailleurs le soir ce qu'ils font
la
[Applaudissements]
jante
j'aime regarder les compile les plus
vues actuellement encore sur internet je
ne sais pas combien d'années après c'est
les compile de l'école des filles
adorent ça marche qu'est ce que j'adore
génial et on est tous jours suivants
j'en étais sûr c'est un copain mois
combien y voit par jour
de trois
mamans voiture un peu
combien de litres abbas et par an et
demi
qu'est-ce qu'il fait dont papa tu sais
de commandes
[Musique]
c'est un bon média monsieur zain et à
maman le travail aussi oui
qu'est-ce qui fait comme métier papa
[Musique]
tu as la pimpine le trajet
est permis à
isabelle et aurait lancé pour
moi c'est ton n'étaient pas amis mais on
se voyait très fréquemment et ont
déjeuné quand on déjeunait sa durée de
13 heures à 18 heures et en repartaient
il repartait souvent dans un état second
combien ne dira pas qu'à cause de
l'alcool d'ailleurs mais il était
profondément malheureux la phrase la
plus importante du doc c'est quand il
dit cette [ __ ] m'a tout pris en
parlant de la télé parce que oui elle va
tout à portée mais ce qu'ils voulaient
profondément sept comédiens sur scène et
avec jean rien et qu'il a vu jean yanne
par tête on est pour chabrol et tout et
lui il n'était pas comme il tient donc
oui il a tout vu sauf ce qu'ils
voulaient c'est à dire profondément
jouer la gagne et visions comme un art
mineur et lui aurait voulu briller dans
d'autres deux ans comme cela n'a pas
marché à forer à chaque fois qu'ils
soient réalisateur voulait oui sa vie de
famille aussi on peut parler de sa vie
de sa famille de huit enfants on voit
des enfants sa fille lui ne se fiait à
parler dans paris-match ya pas longtemps
elle a expliqué le seul moment où elle a
pu partager des moments privilégiés avec
lui c'est quand il était malade oui et
quand elles le ramener dans ses valises
et lui disait il lui disait non ne me
laisse pas en reste avec moi et c'est la
seule fois où il a eu des mots un peu
tendre de cette façon-là année qui élit
ce qu'est ma belle-fille que j'adore et
elle a toujours espéré elle que son papa
lui dit j'aime beaucoup moi je voudrais
moi je voulais absolument et je suis moi
d'être à dire aux gens qu'on les ait moi
je voulais absolument revoir quelque
chose je vous aime
et moi tellement n'a pas l'amour oui
lorsque jacques a su qu'il était cocu
sarkozy c'est bien sûr celle de nicolas
qui les avait molli
un jour à la neige comment à la neige
des vacances l'âge
mais oui oui je peux pas tout vous
raconter non sinon
et il m'a dit un jour tu vois daniel o
il vaut mieux être cocus en amour quand
même l'un amitié à l'humain sa salle a
tué les chocs émotionnels et ben merci
je sais que c'est un petit peu comme je
vais tellement aussi revoir pierre
bondouy frêle ses
émissions les plus cultes je pense
gagner je reçois encore jean paul ii
tellement de choses avec vous qu'il fait
parler longtemps mais je sais bien mais
je vous reçois la semaine prochaine pour
que sont ils devenus chez beaucoup de
ces prochaines
semaines tous les vendredis samedis
bondi prochain bon allez sur l'agenda
vous feuilletez boom dit gilles buna
jada chez moi bon ben c'est pas grave
maintenant j'ai un téléphone 06 82 me
notre nouveau coach et remercie